a pessoa que me incomoda muito e se nem
me arrumei já me Jão você tem um beijão
beijão seguinte ele sabe que a bexiga
dele não suporta um copo d'água ele leva
três latas de refrigerante Fica bebendo
que você sabe que é que eu tô tava
mijada aí vai tá cinco minutos em uma o
bichinho com pingente apertado aí então
só tá tendo de homem já tem como tu
passar só para passar aí Domingo
entretendo com o fio tá tão gostoso lá
ver o cara voltar meus conversador bicho
do Mangá esse cara enfia a mão dele no
coração e te como o direito Aquino Filho
tá com a mão esquerda não tava fazendo o
juiz ao que foi feito não deixa o pior
que é verdade cara bicho é verdade
mastigador